So the two approved ones and one in development, zilivertin and vedotin ADCs, they all have
a common theme.
They do lead to responses and we have invariably relapses.
And so as single agents, they're not that helpful, but they're being used in combinations
and they're used in situations where we need bridging to some other treatments such as
bispecifics or CAR-Ts.
So clearly there's a lot of room for improvement.
So I asked my associate chat GPT to give me a little, of course with my instructions,
to give a little picture of what is coming and what could be coming in the next generation
of ADCs.
So not to be left behind, there will be and there are bispecific ADCs that can go after
two targets.
There will be new warrants.
New warheads, new delivery drugs, such as degraders, rather than just giving chemotherapeutics.
You can combine the payloads, it doesn't have to be just one kind, the new site-specific
conjugation methods being implied in a new targets.
And one that I want to focus a little bit on is ROR1, so not a brand new target anymore,
but it was identified.
As an orphan receptor in 1992 by Dr. Kipps, it's now known that it's actually encoding
a receptor for Win5A.
What is interesting about it, it's an embryonic antigen that's expressed during embryogenesis,
but virtually not at normal tissues in real life anymore, except when malignancies occur
and cancer cells remind themselves of their maybe embryonic origin.
So they do express to various degrees.
ROR1, particularly heme malignancies, but across the board, many solid cancers do this
as well.
So Xiluvertimab-Vidotin was developed as an ADC targeting ROR1 and delivering the good
old payload MMAE.
It was initially developed by a company, Malus Bio, and it was taken over by Merck.
So where is Xiluvertimab-Vidotin going these days?
You see on the right side, it's single-agent activity in relapsed refractory large cell
lymphoma.
It does activity, but then rapid relapses.
So there's activity in frontline trial development right now.
There was a study of it in large cell lymphoma with 15 out of 15 patients responding.
It was a short follow-up, reported at ASH24.
In combination, it is compared with R-CHOP, so Xiluvertimab-Vidotin.
Plus R-CHP versus R-CHOP, following the polar-tuzumab theme.
But because there is polar-tuzumab, there's the study at the bottom, where the two ADCs,
Polar and Xiluvertimab-Vidotin, are being compared, particularly in GCP DRPCRs, because Polar
didn't improve outcomes in that setting.
So that's where maybe there might be a niche for Xiluvertimab-Vidotin.
Now, Immunome also has a ROR1 ADC, a new target, but also a new payload.
So they're delivering a topoisomerase inhibitor.
They have an undisclosed clevo linker, and they have a high load of drug-to-antibody
of eight.
So this ADC comes highly armed, and it's going on in trials right now.
We're having it in startup at UCLA as well, so I look forward to testing this ADC as well.
Now, Dennis Sleiman, our division chief at UCLA, has this TORA lab, and there they identified
a G-protein coupler receptor that was specifically expressed in heme and lymphoid tissues as
opposed to normal tissues.
So highly expressed in B cells, NT cells, and myeloid cells.
And the exact description of this G-protein coupler receptor is not public yet.
You have to be under a CDA, and then you're known.
If you look at different malignancies, it is highly expressed in AML and in large B
cell informers, but not much in other malignancies, as you can see from this survey.
If you look at a cell line bank.
Sleiman lab has several hundred cell lines across the board.
It's really expressed in myeloma, lymphoma, and AML.
But that's it.
Here you see a mouse model where mice-bearing human large lymphoma cells were treated with
either a naked antibody or different doses of the ADC, and you could get to 100% tumor
growth inhibition with the high ADC.
And that's the highest load of the ADC.
And so this study was just opened at UCLA, and we treated the first patients two weeks
ago.
It's the first in-human open-label TOL-5700 study, first in monotherapy and then also
planned in combination with Vitaxa.
Patients that are eligible for these studies are relapsed refractory non-Hodgkin lymphomas,
including low-grade transformed and high-grade lymphomas.
In part one, we're looking at dose finding.
We don't require the targeted expression, but it will be a requirement for part two.
So in part two, there will be dose expansions in de novo large lymphomas and mandelcellar
lymphoma and follicular lymphomas, grade 1 to 3a, and then in part three, there are plans
to start with non-Hodgkin lymphomas.
In part two, there will be dose expansions.
And in part three, there will be dose expansions.
And in part four, there will be dose expansions.
And in part five, there will be dose expansions.
And in part six, there will be dose expansions.
And in part seven, there will be dose expansions.
And in part eight, there will be dose expansions.
And in part nine, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 10, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 11, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 12, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 13, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 14, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 15, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 16, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 17, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 18, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 19, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 20, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 21, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 22, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 23, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 24, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 25, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 26, there will be dose expansions.
And in part 27, there will be dose expansions.